next I call the nagging wife now the
nagging wife is the wife and and
sometimes women have archetypes of more
than one the nagging wife is is the
woman whose husband can never do
anything right she will Nag on him for a
lifetime it doesn't matter if he's a
world-renowned superstar if he's a top
1% guy nothing he does is ever good
enough and you can identify this wife um
by
seeing a woman that disrespects her guy
in public kind of belittles him I was
trying to think of how I could describe
the Jada pinket Smith wives now these
wives um typically have hyphenated La
they don't want to completely submit to
the authority of the man that they're
with